a film screening at the Blue Nile
Academy Ethiopia's only film school
today student get a two years and Gao is
presenting his first film a documentary
about Rastafari the film screening is
free but trainer Abraham Haley burrow is
not quite satisfied with its
cinematography the guy is a little bit
dark so he need more light to see and
then maybe he can come more closer to
that guy that we can concentrate on the
dialogue or on the interview what he's
saying
Abraham Haley Barrow is a cameraman and
a filmmaker his films have won
international awards because there was
no film school in Ethiopia
he studied in the Netherlands now he
wants to teach young filmmakers in his
home country in Tunisian economy to to
Creek up the quality of cinema here that
young talent can learn because there is
no cinema school here at all so for me
is very important that this young talent
can learn what cinema it is and that I
can support a little bit after a year of
initial training the students can choose
their major cinematography screenwriting
directing or editing Abraham has already
trained more than a hundred and forty
up-and-coming filmmakers at his own
expense the school does not receive any
state support is financed by myself so I
am well-paid as European cinematographer
then I can't finance my school this my
problem is the equipment because I must
pay three hundred percent incoming tax
with the equipment
that's not easy with no way of promoting
the films and high taxes the Ethiopian
government makes it difficult for
filmmakers to do their work in this
increasingly authoritarian state the
government fears critical artists so its
sensors assess every film before its
release
if you make your movie there is a desire
to resume and cultural Pierrot you need
to have a permission allowance of
screening from this agency that means
this agency can block you if they are
not happy with the message what we have
Abraham says that for this reason many
of his colleagues prefer to deal with
less contentious topics that's why I
think most of them running to the
committee because then you know it's
only to laugh for people not serious to
think about the issue what's going on in
the country the problem what we have the
social issues etc etc
despite these problems the Ethiopian
film industry is booming every year 100
films are produced here mostly romantic
comedies as a Medusa I have to work on
market-oriented films there's onerous
that we produce right now are just
romantic comedies because that's what
the market wants the films are well
received by Ethiopian audiences but
Abraham has bigger plans for the
country's film industry that our movie
compete with other African countries and
also with Arab why not because we
understand cinema that's not a question
state censorship and poor infrastructure
make life difficult for young filmmakers
but they refuse to give up their passion